ich hätte gerne sein
ja können sie mir da eine bestimmte
sorte empfehlen die alemannia die
überhaupt möchten sie diese rampe auf
eine pizza zum beispiel oder zum
baguette oder zum abend fliegen
es gibt wunderbar wenn sie etwas
milderes möchten die klassische deutsche
salon es gibt eine sehr leckere
italienische mailänder salami
das ist eine spanische baguette salami
hat auch ein verband dadurch ist das
kräftige hoch
auch sehr lecker ist die französische
war gestern am milden geschmack auch
sehr lecker der truppe samani finden sie
auch gerne mal etwas probieren denn sie
möchten
jackman
da schmeckt eindruck haben ich denke ich
wird man diese trüffel salami probiert
schmeckt sehr gut und sehr interessant
[Musik]
152 in orten lassen 252 außerdem noch
ein buch das erst dann kann geschäft
entschuldigung für susanne könnten sie
mir verraten wo ich meist finde sie
bekommen sie zwei kinder dankeschön
gemüsekonserven hier finden sie den
meist einmal der großen pause vorne
einmal der kleinen boot
[Musik]